retractable causal reason
s
[Music]
oops let's get some stuff
great
thank you
um so
hello everyone I just introduce myself
I'm Benji wank
um I just finished my PhD at the
University of Oxford
um here is a research fellow for a
semester and then
um next uh after this I had to start a
postdoc at UCLA
um so yeah I'm gonna talk to you about
probabilistic and logical circuits for
tractable causal reasoning
um I'm very fortunate that I'm I'm
speaking to you straight after yujung so
hopefully circus will still be still be
fresh in your mind but I'll give you a
little bit of an introduction to
causality or at least causality as I see
it
um okay so you know what's my view on
what causality is right look there's uh
uh you know a lot of people in different
fields who would have different
interpretations of course that ID
economists for example uh but I'll just
give you my view so uh my view is
essentially you have some underlying
mechanical or physical system which is
probably too complex to model right
um and then you're sort of
um way of inferring or trying to sort of
reason about what's going on in the
system is that uh you sort of observe
some probability distribution over over
what's going on in this system so
um that's represented by this by this uh
yeah P or P of X over over some some set
of variables X
um but not everything that you want to
understand about what's going on in the
system for example the the questions of
why is something happening or what will
happen if I change something uh can be
captured in in this probability
distribution so my view of sort of
causality is as this sort of
intermediate abstraction between uh
mechanical sort of physical description
of a system and a probabilistic
description so essentially for every
sort of mechanical description you can
derive a causal description and from
every sort of causal description you can
then derive a probabilistic description
um and the sort of advantage of doing
this is that uh by working on on this
causal level you have sort of a richer
model and also the ability to sort of
have a have a richer and more expressive
query language so let me just give you a
sort of simple example of this
um hopefully start them using as well so
um okay so here's basically a
probabilistic question right so on
average uh what percentage of people
fall asleep in a in a CS talk with with
no math
um so this is very very easy to to to to
do right I can just go around to a load
of different CS talks sort of see if
there's math or not in the talk and then
okay like how many people are falling
asleep let's just look around the room
um so so this is something you can
observe purely from from this
probability distribution right
um but then there are a bunch of
questions which you you can't uh just
just just uh uh sort of even formulate
in terms of the probability distribution
so an Interventional question might be
uh what percentage of of people in the
audience would fall asleep if every
speaker was forced to remove all of
their math right and and this this might
be different because you know there may
maybe maybe some some correlations
between the sort of audiences uh uh
people are speaking to and sort of how
much math they want to they want to put
in
um but yeah this is something which I
can't do you know just by going around
and observing it right I have to
actually go and you know do some uh do
some prompting to some speakers
um and then there's this sort of
um contractual question which is uh what
percentage of people would have fallen
asleep in this talk if I had removed all
my math in this talk
um it's probably a bit too late for that
but
um that's another question you can ask
sort of once you have this richer
formalism so basically the idea is with
you know probabilistic inference you
might have some data right describing
the distribution that you're that you're
observing along with some some
probabilistic query and then you come to
some conclusions
um the difference here is that we have
these causal queries which are a little
bit more expressive than the and then
purely probabilistic queries and to sort
of have have sort of models which are
are capable of sort of differentiating
between these uh situations you need
sort of these causal assumptions which
are often encoded as a causal graph like
you see here
um
so I'm going to go over two sort of
causal problems
which should
hopefully give you a bit of insight into
the sort of problems which I'm
interested in working on so
um okay so first let's sort of formalize
what I was saying before so let's say we
have a set of variables X and then we
have some disjoint subsets a and Y
um and then we're interested in this
cause of effect which is uh essentially
the the probability distribution on on y
given that you intervene on a right and
this do a might look a bit weird but the
idea is just that we this is just like
when I was talking about forcing
speakers to to uh you know forcing
speakers to not include maths in in
their talks right
um so
yeah in general this is not going to be
the same as as the conditional
distribution and this is just basically
stating that that correlation is not
necessarily A causation
um
so the way you can sort of
um you know formulate what this means or
sort of
um
um you know what is this query on uh you
have uh in addition to your probability
distribution you also need to specify
these course assumptions on the system
in the form of the causal diagram so
here are sort of two basic examples of
course or diagrams where uh each each
letter is like a set of variables right
and this sort of represents the sort of
qualitative causal structure of the of
the of the of the domain so uh you can
view sort of these solid arrows as
basically direct Equalization right
um and okay so given given a causal
diagram
given some some causal query like this P
of Y given do a uh then in some cases
you can actually derive these
expressions and what these expressions
are are effectively functions of the
data right so all of these P are just
functions of the of the sort of normal
probability distribution but then these
sort of formally give you the uh the
give you an expression for for the for
this Interventional cause of effect
um and the reason we have these two
different ones is that these correspond
to what the formula would be in these
two different graphs so depending on the
graph you get sort of different
different functions of the observed
distribution
um
Okay so
let's sort of talk about what what sort
of computational problems we have here
so let's say we have you know we have
this observed distribution P of X right
maybe we have some machine learning
model we have some other model which
we've learned from data or somehow we've
managed to get this observed
distribution so the question I want to
ask is for which causal graphs or causal
formulas is this cause of effect
tractable
um so this is saying yeah for example if
if before speakers to to not have math
then how will this affect the proportion
of people who who fall asleep in the in
the lectures so
um
okay so for example for for this back
door uh query which we saw before it's
basically like this but we've put in
specific values for y and a right so
lowercase just means we we put in
specific instantiations for yna
um and okay what's sort of interesting
here is that let's say that P is given
by a probabilistic circuit so the sorts
of circuits we saw
um uh just just uh just before in
Eugene's talk
um well it turns out that if uh you just
want the conditional distribution P of Y
given a uh then this is can be computed
in linear time uh if p is decomposable
and smooth so this basically is
um just uses the the marginal inference
algorithm
um which usually described uh where you
effectively just divide P of Y A by uh P
of a
um but it turns out this sort of causal
effect this this Interventional effect
sort of Define defined above is actually
uh turns out to be sharply hard to
compute
um even if P satisfies these sort of uh
more stringent conditions so
um called structure decomposability
smoothness and determinism so these
um properties are pretty much as uh as
strong as it gets when it comes to
circuits so basically if we can't uh you
know if this isn't tractable under these
conditions then we're we're really in
trouble
um
okay so this is an interesting sort of
separation between
um just just these uh conditionals and
these causal effects but
um okay like is there some property that
we can impose on the circuit so is there
some way we can restrict the space of of
models or circuits that we're looking at
such that we can actually compute
sufficiently and it turns out the answer
is is yes so uh basically if p is given
by a structure decomposable in what's
called marginally deterministic circuit
uh then there is a a quadratic time
algorithm for for computing this causal
effect
um and this is quadratic in the size of
the circuit okay
um and so the sort of uh idea behind
this marginally deterministic term I
won't go into the full details but uh in
this case basically uh if you look at
the circuit on the left you'll see that
we have two branches at the root note
right uh and on the left Branch we have
values of a and z uh corresponding to
them both being true or both being false
uh on the right side we have values of A
and Z corresponding to one of them being
true
um and so these sort of branches are
kind of contradictory with respect to
those variables and and that's kind of
the key condition that you need in order
to turn it into a uh into a circle
representing this this causal effect
which is what you see on the right
um okay so this is only for the back
door case right so I showed you the back
door graph and then the back door
formula that you get in this case for
the causal effect uh but it turns out
that for these two other common types of
graphs you can also get uh these sort of
uh polynomial time algorithms for for
computing this so so this is quite nice
we have a sort of we've what we've done
is we've gone in we've sort of tried to
figure out what is the Restriction we
need to put on our class on our sort of
class of circuits uh and then uh how
does that lead to a a tractable
algorithm for uh or an efficient
algorithm for for computing this
um okay so now I'm going to talk about
the second problem which
um I'm not gonna
introduce or talk about any course or
terms here I'm just going to give it
purely in a graphical sense
um and then you can talk to me later if
you if you want to uh learn about the
cause and interpretation
um but basically what this problem is is
okay so we have some directed a site
click off G with a weight Matrix and
then we want to compute this this Matrix
and what what this is saying is
basically
um you know over all past some of our
from a node I to a node J uh we want the
sort of sum over all Paths of the
products of Weights along that path okay
um and you know this is sort of uh you
know quite a simple problem
um in the sense that it can easily be
solved by by matrix inversion so
um if you think of this B and B squared
and B Cubed this is like you know the
contributions from your uh length one
pass and your length two parts and then
three parts and then you get this this
uh this Matrix inverse which which gives
you the The Matrix C right
um and I should mention that we want the
whole Matrix C so we want all pairs of
we want this for all pairs of IG
um and so okay you can apply sort of
Matrix inversion algorithms and that's
all fine
um but let's say now that
um the graph and possibly also the
weight Matrix but let's sort of focus on
the graph uh is given by some
probability distribution then we want
sort of the expectation of this Matrix C
over this probability distribution okay
um
and so of course you know whether this
is possible or not depends on what this
probability distribution is uh if p is a
uniform distribution of a Dax it's
likely hard because
um we we because you know even sort of
trying to trying to represent the
uniform distribution over dags in any
any kind of charitable manner is is is
uh pretty much possible
um but it turns out that uh okay so are
there interesting classes of
distributions P
um for which this expectation is
tractable and yeah maybe you can you can
think about this
um maybe this pops up in some other
setting and then and then there are some
interesting classes distributions there
but in the specific causal setting uh
that that's uh motivated this problem
um it turns out that yes there there is
a particular type of circuit which is
useful representing this probability
distribution P under which this
expectation uh turns out to have have uh
have an algorithm um
which is uh n cubed times P where uh n
is the number of vertices in in the
graph
um
so okay so so the sort of idea here was
just to to give an idea of
um sort of how you know causality
you know is a sort of is interesting
both in terms of
um you know both in times of the
application cases both in terms of sort
of you know philosophically what it
means but it also gives rise to some
some interesting uh interesting
computational problems which which may
have some some interesting theory behind
them as well
um
okay so I'll talk a bit about some some
open questions and and topics and then
I'll wrap up so uh the first sort of
question I have here is that
um we've just seen that for a few graphs
so the back door the front door and the
napkin
um that's actually you know under some
marginal determinism conditions
um these cause effects can actually be
be computed uh on circuits in polynomial
time so
the natural question then is like okay
if we look at all possible graphs right
all possible graphs where you know the
cause of effect is identifiable
um is it always like this and sort of I
have reasons to believe no but
um I haven't proved it so
um yeah the next question is if not can
we sort of somehow characterize this
dichotomy between you know cases where
the causal effect is tractable in cases
where it's not uh in terms of the causal
growth
um
so I also gave you some sort of uh
complexity
um upper bounds for
for some of these
um cases like the back door but there
are reasons to believe that that that we
can do better so for example
um for the back door case if you impose
a a slightly more restrictive condition
then uh it actually becomes linear time
um but yeah we want to sort of figure
out for these certain subclasses of
circuits
um you know can we also show lower
bounds for complexity uh even if it's
polynomial time
um can we can we approximate uh hard
queries efficiently so
um you know for example for the back
door case like uh if we were just given
some circle which doesn't satisfy the
conditions required or perhaps some some
other representation the probability
distribution can can we in some sense
approximate approximate this
um and also this this sort of marginal
condition determinism condition which I
mentioned
um it's actually quite interesting
because it's a general realization of um
sort of Fairly well-known properties in
both logical and probabilistic circuits
so for example strong determinism
decision properties so very very related
to that and obds and things like this so
if we can sort of show that the these
sort of slightly more General circuits
are more succinct than those previous
circuits and that that will be another
uh uh another step in the right
direction
um yeah but anyway that's that's all I
had for for today so
um yeah thanks everyone
thank you very much
any questions
I've never thought about it not
impossible so
um
so from the space of so so firstly if
you have sort of a uniform distribution
of the space of dags if you want to do
something like uh
um you know if you want to do something
like finding finding marginal
distributions over over edges that's
that's that's that's going to be hard
um and in this case I'm talking about
um okay taking this uniform distribution
and then attempting to compute this
expectation where each each possible dag
corresponds to a different one of this
right so so so that that is uh yeah the
Asic listing condition really really
sort of puts you in trouble
any other questions
thanks indeed to all the speakers of the
session and uh should give a round of
applause to indeed all speakers for the
day for really a round of uh very
Illuminating and thought-provoking talks
on
lovely topics with lots of activity so
thanks everyone
and also thanks to the audience for